hello everyone today was around 13 the
final round of the 2018 Tata Steel chess
tournament Magnus Carlsen drew his game
against Sergey kurakin and onigiri drew
his game against Wei Yi Crossen finishes
game with Kirk in a bit sooner then Giri
finished his game against wayy but way
he played a solid game and he didn't
give Gary any chances to actually go for
the win
so after 13 rounds Yuri and Carson are
tied in first place and they will now
play a two game match they have to go
into tiebreaks so this is the first game
of the Thai barracks crossing has the
white pieces and he opens the game with
Knight to f3
we have Knight to f6 c4 we have e 6 and
b3 d 5 by earring Bishop to b2 Bishop to
e7 e 3 now we have castles Knight to c3
c5 now seek after Sun d5 Knight captures
on d5 Knight captures on d5 and it
captures on d5 and d4 by Carlsen Queen
to a5 Czech Queen to d2 and Carlsen
offers a trade of Queens he doesn't mind
going straight into the endgame Queen
captures King captures and Knight to c6
d captures on c5 bishops casters on c5
and Bishop to b5 now Bishop to b4 check
King 32 and Bishop to e6 here rook a to
c1 was played rook a to c8 both players
simply putting putting their pieces on
optimal squares rook H to d1 Bishop to
e7 and h3 by crossing preparing g4 we
have a six Bishop to d3
Knight to be for attacking both the
bishop on d3 and the pawn on a two so
Bishop to b1 and rook captures on c1
rock characters and rook a roof to c8
and here across and doesn't want to
trade both pairs of rooks he plays rook
to d1 as Geary does have an isolated
pawn here on d5 and Carlson would like
to make this pawn a target so Knight to
c6 and we have g4 and this g4 is a very
important move cross ins idea will be to
play h3g for and later on push F
for in their five and trade off this
light square bishop for this light
square bishop and then he will have his
bones fixed on light squares and he will
try to fix gear response on dark squares
but we'll get to that h6 nights the d4
Knight captures Bishop captures and
Bishop to a3 not allowing this rook to
have this C 1 square and sorry and also
may be preparing rook to c1 to trade off
that rook as well here we had F 4 and F
6 FF 5 is pushed so bishop has the F 7
square for it and the bishop to g6 by
Carlsen now King to f8 and here comes
King to f3 King to e7 Gary also improves
the position of his King we have h4
Bishop to b4 now and Bishop to d3 Bishop
to d7 and here you have to find a
applying here for white hear the
commentators spoke of rook to G 1
preparing g5 that this would be
excellent for white and Carlsen here
shocked everyone when he played efore as
it's a it's a weird move because here
across and has four connected pawns and
this isolated d5 pawn should be a
weakness and when cross and pushed efore
he allowed gira to exchange his weak
bond for crossings connected pawn but
cross and is very confident in this
endgame he will have a much more active
King and he will try to exchange like I
said the light square bishop and fix his
pawns on light squares bishop the sea 3
by giri bishop to f2 Carlson doesn't
want to exchange the dark square bishop
we have bishop the c6 now pawn captures
Bishop captures and Bishop to e4 Bishop
captures kink captures and here it's
hard to say what do you play
not when you look at this position
Carlson's position is much better he has
a much more active King his pawn
structure under under Kings that is much
better because he has f5 and h5
available for him which will fix all of
gear responds on dark squares and
Carlsen
the dark square bishop so those bonds
will be targets and here you want to
play something like Bishop to b2 or
Bishop to b4 not allowed this nasty pin
with rook to c1 and Gary didn't think
there was this was a worth worrying
about so he played King to e6 cross and
immediately pushed f5 who helped King to
e7 and now rip the c1 pinning this
bishop here and here again you want to
play something like King to d7 to
protect the rook and then move the
bishop but Gary decided to play King a
rook to c6 King to D 3 by Carlsen now
with a double attack on the bishop on c3
and Bishop to b4 but this allows Carson
now to play rook captures on c6 and
after be captures on c6 now the pawn
structure is ruined over on the Queen
side and although the material is
completely equal both players 5 points
both players a dark square bishop it's
it's a winning position for white and
the reason is like I already said the
broken bones on the Queen side and the
points on the King side are on dark
squares across and has a dark square
bishop so these pawns are target's and
Gary's Bishop is gonna be very much
useless against cross since King side
pawns as they are all on light squares
after he pushes h5 so King to c4 going
after those Queen side pawns and
improving the position of his own King
Bishop to d6 and the Bishop to c5 now
like I said even even with the bishops
traded off it's a winning game so
capturing the bishop would only favor
white here King to d7 was played first
h5 by Carlsen Bishop to f4 and Bishop f8
now attacking the g7 pawn King to e8 and
here cross and decided not to grab the
g7 phone
although the g7 point can be taken but
it's a blitz game you don't want to you
don't want to trap your bishop for
nothing if you're not sure but it's it's
a better position for white so no need
to ruin it by playing something that
might not work but actually you can
capture it after Bishop captures King to
a7 attacking the bishop you play Bishop
to h8 and now you still can't stress
but because Bishop captures on f6 so
first have to protect the pawn but now
King c5 now the King will grab the Queen
side pawns Bishop to c3 first you have
to at least protect that one point after
King captures you have a five and after
King attacks the a5 pawn now after you
threaten the bishop this bishop would
capture d f6 pawn bishop captures and
after King captures you have four extra
pawns
two of them are passed pawns on the
Queen side it's completely winning
position for for white so after this
King to here to move cross and play
Bishop back to c5 King back to the seven
and now King 2b for going after the a6
pawn bishop to d2 check not allowing the
King to approach the pawn we have King
to a four and now King to c7 before here
now the thread is of course King gave
five king characters and a six as now
this pawn is blocking bishops influence
and e8 v square we had Bishop to f4
Bishop to f8 now attacking the g7 pawn
and Geary had to give up the g7 point he
has he he wants to try at least again
some activity here we have King to G
King to b6 preventing the White King
from going to a5 Bishop captures Bishop
to g5 now protecting those pawns and
Bishop to f8 we have Bishop to f4 and
it's the one way very interesting thing
is that if this bishop ever moves from
protecting the g5 square Carlsen simply
pushes g5 and this will most likely be
winning whichever pawn captures then
either H pawn goes up the board or F
pawn goes up the board so Bishop to
Bishop to e7 now attacking the f6 pawn
push back to g5 defending King to b3
came to c7 now King to see for King to
d7 Bishop to c5 and now all Carlson has
to do is play King to d3 Bishop to e3
and force an exchange of this dark
square bishop and being upon up it's a
completely winning endgame and this is
exactly what happens King c7 we have
King to d3 King the 7 and Bishop to e3
and it was in this position that giri
resigned the game so game 1 of the tie
breaks when
the cross and there's really nothing you
can do here you if you exchange then the
pony game is winning for white your only
other option is to do nothing then white
will capture here and create either an F
past one or an H pass pawn or you can
play something like Bishop to h4
allowing Bishop captures and h6 now
we're down two points this is just
terrible so yeah it's a very it's a
beautiful win I mean it's such a nice
technical when that so seems like a
completely equal endgame but it's really
not and crossing Saudis when he pushed
that e4 pawn he knew that his position
would be much better and well when you
were playing blitz and you have a better
position it's it's a lot easier to win
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it for those of you who haven't
heard about the result or something I
will not spoil the result of the second
game as I not sure if I will be able to
show it so second game also a second
game was wrong here we've tried very
hard to create some sort of an attack
even sacrificed a piece but Crossin
immediately gave the piece back and he
managed to draw the second game so with
one and a half points out of two games
Magnus Carlsen is the 2018 Tata Steel
chess tournament winner
so he's the champion and this is the
sixth time that he won this title so
that's the record no one want that was
still six times so an amazing tournament
and an amazing match here a two game a
match against onigiri and it's it's too
bad for Geary I mean he played a perfect
tournament he didn't lose a single game
but in the end
Coulson managed to help to take the
victory away from him so yeah I hope I
will manage to show you the second game
as well and that's it for the tata steel
tournament i do hope you enjoyed my
coverage of this tournament and now i
will probably turn my attention to to
the Giro tour chess festival and after
that and then i will want to
returned to the classics so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed everything as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon
oh sorry I forgot I prepared this this
is the handshake after the game so Geary
resigned shook his hand and that's
that's it a very nice photo so yeah see
you soon